♪ She's sexy, she's sexy ♪
♪ So so so so sexy ♪
- [Nathan] The mall manager.
What's your name again?
I'm just an elf.
Wait, oh, do you like your
photo taken with Santa?
It's five dollars only.
It's a discounted prices because
it's earlier in the year.
Excuse me, okay, come.
Okay.
(walkie talkies talking)
Okay, can you stay away
from the cameras, please?
You can't go in front, please
you can't go in front of,
please can you stay away
from our camera person.
Okay, we're going, we are
leaving.
- Nathan, do you want me to stop
him?
I said does he want me to stop
you.
(laughing)
You've never messed with
Santa Claus, have you?
- All right, no it's okay.
James, I'm out of the door, stop
it.
James, come with me.
(Christmas instrumental music)
- Okay, I know we're both, we're
both trying to do our jobs.
Okay, don't swear there's kids
around.
Do not swear, there's kids
You can't swear when
there's children around.
Yes, I'm walking.
We're both trying to do our
jobs, okay?
You can't think your job's
more important than mine.
Stay back, please.
After giving Amber and Jeremiah
their official uniforms
we had our first employee
orientation
to go over some company
policies.
So, because of the size of the
company,
I'm also the HR department here.
So, we need to go over the code
of conduct
when it comes to relationships
in the workplace.
Because sexual tension is
something that's very
distracting
in the workplace, if you
find yourself attracted
to another employee that
also needs to be disclosed.
Amber, do you want to go first.
- Wow, okay, well I mean
everybody's different
so like for me personally
attraction is more than just.
- I mean who out of the
people you work with
are you attracted to the
most, including bosses?
- Uh, wow, okay I'll go with
you.
- Me?
- Yeah.
- So, out of everyone you work
with,
you 're most attracted to me?
Right, and you heard that, or?
- Yeah, I heard that yeah, loud
and clear.
- So mine, I guess would be you
and Jeremiah, I guess no one
picked you but for the record
I guess I do need to know who
you are most attracted to?
- I'd have to say her.
- Amber?
- Yeah.
- Okay, well obviously
you know she did pick me.
So, that is unlikely to happen
there.
But it's good that I do
know that for the record
and I think the fact that
we've talked about it
now we can continue working as
peers
without there being any
awkwardness.
- Okay.
♪ So sexy, so sexy, so so so so
sexy ♪
- Do you want to see a magic
trick?
- Oh, sure.
- Do you like magic?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just a little.
- Yeah, why not.
- Okay, see that coin?
- I see it.
- Okay (blowing)
- I think I've seen that before.
- Okay.
Now that I had impressed
Elle, it was time to see
if I could get her to admit
that there was something more
going on with the Best
Buy price match policy
than meets the eye.
One cool thing about Hot Topic
is that they're pretty lax
on the rules, you know, we
can kind of do what we want
a little bit.
For example we have
this price match policy,
sometimes like someone will come
in
with a legitimate price match
and if I'm not feeling it
I'll just be like no,
you know what I mean?
You guys ever do that or?
- Oh, I've seen it happen, yes.
- At Best Buy?
- Mhmm.
- You've seen what?
- Other people not do it because
they're--
- Not do the price match?
- Yeah, because they're
not feeling the person.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- That's crazy.
- And there it was, the smoking
gun.
On camera evidence of a
culture of corruption,
eroding the insides of one of
America's
most respected institutions.
But even though I had what I
needed I didn't want to be rude
and leave abruptly so I decided
to stay
for the private salsa lesson I
had prearranged for the date.
- (speaking Spanish)
How are you guys doing?
You're supposed to move
your shoulders, your hips,
and your arms as well.
I have to admit I was a
bit nervous about dancing
but once we got going, I
discovered I was actually
really good at it.
- Look at his eyes, he's
waiting for you, perfect.
- And once our date was
over, we said our goodbyes.
- Nice meeting you.
- Okay, yeah, see ya.
- Bye.
♪ She's sexy, so sexy, so so so
so sexy ♪
Oh sweet, look, open 24 hours.
- What is it?
- Looks like some sort of
store but look, free pizza,
do you see it, it's right back
there.
It's right there in the
back like a heat lamp.
- Let's go, you're coming with
me?
- Yeah yeah.
(bell rings)
(glass clanking)
Are you okay, man?
- I'm all right right now.
- All right, you better be
careful.
- It's all right.
(clanking)
- Watch your back.
(crashing and glass breaking)
- There's no way, I can't
even fit through that,
it's too tight.
- But what do you, I mean do
you want the pizza or what?
(glass breaking)
- I'm kind of wedged here.
- You broke this stuff.
- Right, that's why I'm
like I don't want to really
break any more because it's
(beeps) it's super expensive.
- You have a you break
it you buy it policy?
- Yeah.
♪ She's sexy, so sexy, so so so
so sexy ♪
- [Nathan] Using our intake
we loaded in over 30 pounds
of Robert's product that had
been blended into a thin paste
to ensure an even flow without
compromising the flavor.
So, with that I activated
the pump and it was time
to see if this could work.
As I had hoped the pump
dispensed
the chili at a steady pace
which was good, but I
realized we had overlooked
a crucial detail.
The chili suit prevented
bathroom access
and because of it's weight
removing it during a game
would not be an option, so
I experimented with a design
that would allow me to
deposit my excretions
directly into custom rubber
underwear
connected to a secondary pumping
system,
so I could eject it into
a toilet via a second tube
down my right arm.
But once I had some clothing on
I realized
the potential for a costly
mix up was too great
so I had the bottom part
of the suit redesigned
with strategic holes in the
groin and buttocks region
that would allow the wearer
to relieve him or herself
without taking off the suit.
But for my plan to work
I would need to be able
to sell chili for an entire
game without getting caught,
so I decided to start in the
upper levels
where security was thinner.
I moved through the stadium like
a ninja
switching sections after each
sale so I couldn't be tracked.
At one point I thought
security was on my tail
but I was able to lose the guy
by ducking
into a handicap bathroom
after which I reemerged
and resumed by operation.
I can serve it to you right now,
I have it right under my
clothes.
I sold 16 bowls of
delicious chili that night,
right under the noses
of stadium management
and that meant from this day
forward
Robert had a proven
method to sell his chili
at Robobank Arena.
♪ So sexy, so sexy, so so so so
sexy ♪
And later that week posing
as a big time record producer
I opened my doors to the
best of what LA had to offer.
All right, let's see
what you've got my man.
- Sure.
(clears throat)
Don't look at the clock it's
deceiving,
everything you also dependent
on perceiving the future.
Fickle motions of your mind,
dust reaches of this Earth
always contemplating time
to a setting the extreme
many of us travel.
Sheep are thou shepherds
and non prepare for battle--
- [Nathan] The turnout was
better than I had expected
and it was clear right away
I was drowning in talent.
♪ Arise the time is now ♪
So after auditioning
a drummer named Chris,
who could really pound the skins
and Yanni, a physically
attractive singer
who had the right kind of
ambition.
- I mean on a wider perspective
like I want the whole world
to hear what I have to say.
- My band was starting to take
shape.
- This is freedom to me.
- But I still needed to
figure out which musician
was best suited to
playing the smoke detector
so I organized the band's first
rehearsal
and after watching them jam
(instrumental music playing)
It quickly became clear that
the stand out talent was Eddy.
(electric guitar playing)
He was not only the best
musician
but also the best showman.
If anyone could make the smoke
detector work, it was him
so after rehearsal was
over I kept Eddy behind
to show him his new instrument.
- I can sing, I can play the
drums,
this is not an instrument.
- It is, it's a blue smoke
detector.
(beeping)
- No, no.
- This is going to be the
thing that separates us
from any other band.
- Okay.
- And that means the guy
who plays it is going to be
the most famous, you want
to be famous, don't you?
- Um.
♪ So sexy, so sexy, so so so so
sexy ♪
- [Nathan] I was worried
that if his love life
remained unfulfilled he
might not have the confidence
he would need to step into
his new role as a hero
so I decided to create
an online dating account
for Corey that I populated with
photos
from his Facebook page.
I also created some new images
that would help portray Corey
as a sensitive guy that women
would be unable to resist.
And shortly after uploading
them to his profile
it seemed to work, as by the
next morning I had a response
from a lovely woman named
Jasmine who seemed like
she might be a good fit for
Corey.
And after telling her that a
camera crew was following me
because I was going to be
performing a death defying
wire walk, she instantly
agreed to go on a date,
which I set for the following
night.
My goal was to establish a
relationship
that Corey would ultimately take
over.
So I tried my best to portray a
realistic
but charming version of the
man whose skin I was in.
I've just spent most of my
time in Ventura, you know.
Not the greatest place, but
it's kind of hard to talk
about myself with a Goddess
sitting right in front of me.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah, sorry.
Is that a bit cheesy or?
- No, it's actually really
sweet,
nobody's ever called me that
before.
- I was immediately surprised
at how well the date
was going, as in these
situations
I'm usually a lot more nervous.
- Back in high school I was
actually on the debate team.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- So, what's it like to
debate with you, then.
- I'm pretty good.
- I bet you're a
pretty good arguer.
- Yeah, I'm pretty good at
debating.
- Should we try debate
something now, or I don't know,
it's just a silly joke,
we don't have to do that.
And ten minutes in not
only were Corey and Jasmine
hitting it off.
- So, have you actually tried
walking across a building yet?
- No.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's gonna be nerve
wracking.
- They also had a lot in common.
- Do you play Sims at all?
- I do.
- Yes, so do I, that's my guilty
pleasure.
- Oh yes, it's a guilty pleasure
for me, I love Sims, yeah.
Cool beans.